mich hat eine sache sehr berührt heute
und zwar waren dass die bilder der
kanzlerkandidaten mit den kindern in der
schule ohne maske alle kinder trugen
keine maske ich habe diese bilder
gesehen und war darüber sehr glücklich
endlich kinder lachend ohne maske in der
schule mit den kanzlerkandidaten ich
dachte mir wie schön habe ich irgendeine
verordnung nicht mitbekommen deutschland
dass endlich die massen pflicht für
kinder aufgehoben ist dem war nicht so
es war eine reine werbe show für eine
seit 1 fernsehsendung denn bei diesem
dreh mussten die kinder die masken nicht
tragen wenn sie jetzt glauben dass ich
jetzt seit 1 dafür verurteilen will
überhaupt gar nicht sein 1 hat
anscheinend mehr den durchblick als die
aktuelle politik den kindern mit masken
solltest der schule für meinen geschmack
her nicht mehr geben deswegen hoffe ich
und hella schild frau berbalk ich
verzeihe ihm definitiv auch herr scholz
wenn sie jetzt die masten pflicht sehr
bald für die kinder aufheben nach der
wahl dann verzeichnen sogar dass sie bei
werbe schoss eine ausnahme machen denn
diese ausnahme sollte die regel
[Musik]
ich sehe mich auf das ist als vater von
einer tochter die gerade eingeschult ist
weiß ich ja auch als pädagoge dass
kinder vor allem durch lippen durch
mimik lernen soziale kontakte herstellen
und das ist komplett weg und wir reden
immer über das thema die natürlich
wichtig ist wir müssen auch unsere
kinder schützen aber die für ein
eindimensionaler betrachtung dieser
pandemie dass alle nebenwirkung ein log
downs oder masken tragen oder nicht mehr
in kontakt mit anderen kindern zu sein
das hat folgen und es gibt studien die
zeigen schon seit mehr als ein jahr dass
es störungen depressionen
sozialer kontakte empathie entwicklung
entweder zu nehmen oder abnehmen das
sind probleme die endlich die politik
auch wahrnehmen soll und dann vor allem
konzepte liefern wie von hier weiter
corona bleibt und jetzt müssen wir mit
diesem virus auch leben und lernen wie
man damit leben kann
ich kann diese einschätzungen von mansur
da voll unterschreiben aber was mich
dass ich ganz fragwürdig finde wenn man
dem zuschauer ist eine zier inszenierung
kommen ein paar politiker mann plötzlich
geld in aller regel nicht mehr vorher
war das quasi existenzielle ernstfall
alle müssen die maske an aber muss
diesen armen kindern wie sie haben
völlig richtig gesagt zwingt man diesen
kindern eine maske auf mit all den
entschädigungen und problemen obwohl ja
gar nichts risikogruppe gehören obwohl
die auch die pandemie nicht weiter
verbreiten aber kaum kommen die
herrlichen politiker dann gelten wieder
ganz andere regeln und das ist etwas was
wir in dieser pandemie immer wieder
beobachtet haben dass wir ihnen so mehr
klassen gesellschaften hineingehen dass
politiker für sich regeln in anspruch
nehmen die für die anderen nicht gelten
und das verärgert die leute und die
leute die das dann kritisieren die
werden dann als querdenker aus alu hütte
der verachtung preisgegeben ich finde
das eine hochgradig fragwürdige
geschichte obwohl ich mich auch freuen
wenn die kinder wenigstens für diese für
europäische inszenierung nie was gehabt
sie an meiner wirtschaft bei den kindern
mehr irritationen weil sie begreifen
dass sie das jetzt wohl jemandem anderen
tun nichts weil wir jetzt ein bisschen
frei sein dürfen sondern weil jetzt ein
politiker herkommt und dass halt tut
genauso wenn die kinder maske tragen
aber die lehrerin nicht weil sie das
nicht acht stunden außer also ich glaube
jetzt nicht dass die kinder die bei dem
dreh mitgemacht haben also langfristige
schäden haben weil sie jetzt mal für ein
paar stunden die maske aufziehen mussten
oder ja genau entscheidend ist doch in
der tat welches bild gibt jetzt wieder
die politik ja also seine
wahlkampfveranstaltung nichts anderes
ist das ja und warum spiegelt man da
nicht die realität im land wider und das
wäre so einfach gewesen und man könnte
dann also diese menschen die da diese
drei herrschaften sind ja auch dafür
verantwortlich dass die kinder eben
ausgetragen dann spiegelt das doch bitte
auch im wahlkampf wieder das ist halt
das was die menschen draußen nicht
verstehen ich verstehe es nicht und
sicherlich auch die zwölf kinder die da
in dieser klasse waren das ist absurd
nur weil es eine wahlkampfveranstaltung
ist muss ich doch nicht die rede
nein du ich sag das ist sicherlich eines
der kleinsten über die es gibt also ich
habe kinder die die nicht selber mein
sohn ist erst 15 aber ob es meine
partnerin oder partner
kinder im allgemeinen sind nicht nennen
es ist schon das kleinste übel glaube
ich auch diesen kindern eine maske
aufzuzwingen
wenn sie gar nicht mehr in die schule
gelassen wir uns her die machen
natürlich wirklich die geprügelten zeit
15 16 17 monaten gehen sie in die schule
jeden tag der ganztagsschulen sind sie
bis 16 uhr machen zum großen teil sogar
sport also bei meinem sohn ist das sport
mit der maske sie kommen nach hause und
sind wirklich dann auch unglaublich noch
stark dafür aber ich denke jedes mal
wenn ich da jeden tag so auch noch sport
machen würde mit der maske ich wäre
glaube ich wirklich fertig also das
design und das andere ist was mich daran
stört an dieser geschichte ist natürlich
auch die inszenierung der kinder als
wahlkampf futter im grunde nicht mal wo
sind wir denn eigentlich wir spielen
noch nicht dingsda mit der politik
sondern hier geht es um politische
entscheidungen getroffen werden hier
sind kinder als kulisse missbraucht als
staffage auch von den politikern aktiv
genutzt um sich irgendwie darzustellen
und zwar von allen dreien da hätte ich
tatsächlich als politiker gesagt pass
auf freunde tolle sendung aber ich mache
da nicht mit weil darum geht sich und
meine position gegenüber die kann ich
auch ganz wo anders darstellen da muss
ich nicht hier eine show mit mit mit 810
jährigen hier mitmachen und die kinder
nur als staffage
missbrauchen und da stört ja auch sehr
also was ich an die landes sehr schätze
ist ja eigentlich eine der wirklich
genialen politik strategen in
deutschland und wenn man diese bilder
anschaut dann sieht man doch den
unfassbaren grad der verzweiflung diese
kandidaten das jetzt also schon weiß
auch nicht autokraten sich mit kindern
inszenieren müssen aus der totalen
inhaltslosigkeit seines wahlkampfs musst
du dich jetzt emotional da sozusagen
aufplustern mit diesen kindern das genau
das was sie hier sagen dass man
eigentlich diese kinder missbraucht um
die lehre die man selber verbreite
politisch irgendwo emotional auf zu
finden das ist wirklich auch eine
eigentlich eine finde ich noch
deprimierende feststellung ich meine
aussieht auch noch den kanzler schröder
beraten haben haben wir doch noch ein
bisschen andere
sind wir beide kommen in der schön
deswegen sind wir auch nicht nostalgisch
kommt sondern gucken auf das hier und
jetzt und ich denke schon dass jeder von
ihnen denkt dass er inhalte zu bieten
hat was mich aber daran stört ist dass
sie glauben das mitmachen zu müssen man
nach dem motto der eine sagt ja der herr
laschet ist da wo sie auch hin sagt olaf
scholz oder frau bernburg sagt die
beiden sind da und da muss ich hin da
die größe zu haben zu sagen pass mal auf
freunde ich mache da nicht mit ich meine
frau berg macht nicht mit beim interview
von bild am sonntag und riskiert eine
ganze seite leere seite da hätte sie
auch eher sagen können dass man auch bei
dieser inszenierung mache ich nicht mit
gerade weil sie ja auch kinder hat und
weiß natürlich wie das aber ganz das
eigentlich schon eine verweigerung
überhaupt themen in den wahlkampf zu
spielen ist das eine art realitätsflucht
der politische gau in diese emotionen um
nicht über die themen sprechen ein das
ist es natürlich nicht und dann höre ich
auch auf weil es gibt ja tree elle und
so war es gerade morgen werden wir eins
haben er wundert sich über inhalte
gesprochen und übermorgen und und die
positionen ausgetauscht werden aber ist
ein voller fans wer mit gemacht wird
weil man glaubt dieses emotionale gefäß
auch noch füllen zu müssen und das halte
ich für den wollte ich dir sindbad tage
vor dem wahl und ich hab bis jetzt
wirklich nicht gehört wie es mit ihm
weitergeht und vor allem mit unseren
kindern es gibt nicht diese konzepte
sagt wir machen vielleicht noch einmal
noch einen monat mit maske und danach
nicht mehr oder wir entwickeln jetzt ein
konzept damit wir mit diesem virus leben
konnten diese konzepte gibt es nicht und
das stört mich sehr weil das ist das
thema die die meisten menschen
heutzutage in deutschland beschäftigt
aber da wir noch einmal ganz kurz zu den
kindern gehen weil und wir wissen 1
kinder stellen oftmals die besten fragen
ich habe das ganze sagt einstigen ist
noch nicht gesehen insofern weiß ich
nicht ob er im schnitt auf gute fragen
dabei waren ich finde es aber schon
spannend wie drei spitzenpolitiker auf
möglicherweise sehr naive aber auch
dadurch eben besonders gute fragen von
kindern antworten sich geben also herr
scholz habe eben gerade gesehen also
flöten spielen sollte ein wahlkampf
unterlassen das gesichtsausdruck der
gesichtsausdruck von dem einen hat dann
viel gesagt aber ich finde das nicht so
wahnsinnig aber auch mal eine andere
farbe stimmt das ja
also ich kann nur sagen ich hab ja mal
mit zehn jahren bei der fernsehsendung
teilgenommen da sollte ich der lockvogel
von verona pooth sein ihre mädchen so
etwas mehr redet als verona da kam ich
dann raus das war es war ehrlich gesagt
alles gescriptet was ich gesagt habe
also ich habe vorher so ein drehbuch
bekommen das habe ich zu hause aus wenn
ich mir ja aber wir wissen aber wissen
wir denn jetzt ob die fragen wirklich
also geht seit 1 dahin setzt die kinder
und alle fragen keine ist vorbereitet
müssen wir jetzt 1 1 fragen ich will
jetzt nichts ganz entscheidend ist ja
die frage ob die kandidaten die fragen
woher bekommen haben dass die kinder
fragen an die an die hand kriegen dass
das hilft dann ja vielleicht auch
eine rivalität eine riesige absurdität
wenn ich mich zurückerinnern in dem auto
da hätte ich doch nie irgend einem
politiker eine das hätte ich gar nicht
interessiert als kind hast du ganz
andere sorgen denkst du ein baby stark
und ich weiß auch diese youtube viel mit
der jüngst mit welche games das ist das
thema aber ist jedoch völlig es ist doch
klar woher eigentlich kinder beschäftigt
in china die frage ob sie diese fragen
stellen aber es aber das schöne ist ja
wir haben jetzt noch ein thema was
kinder betrifft
[Musik]